[موسيقى]
نحن نمتلك صالونًا لنحت الشعر بألوان تقنية
في عمق جنوب شرق لندن أولاً
أنشأنا صالون Ilan غير القائم على إصدار الأحكام
والذي يلبي جميع أنواع الشعر والهويات الجنسية ،
هذه مساحة
للجميع وهي مكان آمن ومريح حيث
يمكن للجميع الحضور و
ليحققوا أحلامهم ،
أود أن أقول شخصيًا إن أسلوبي يشبه تمامًا
قماشها المطلي ، وأحب أن أبدو وكأنه
قطعة فنية مشيًا ، وفيللي هو مهرج كوني ،
لقد جئت من مجرة أخرى في لن
ن مصدر إلهام هائل لأ
نا في جولة  الأشخاص المبدعون في الحياة
الذين يعبرون عن أنفسهم على
أساس يومي والذين لا يخافون ولا
يخافون من إحساسنا بتحويل
أنفسنا ونريد أن نشارككم ، وأعلم أنني
أريد أن يشعر الناس بنفس الطريقة ، وهذا هو
الهدف من متجرنا هو
إلهام العالم
[  موسيقى]